[Music]
estonia latvia and lithuania the
so-called baltic republics have
experienced one of the highest economic
growth processes in the world over the
last three decades which explains new
stories like this
statistics don't lie in the end we are
richer than the spanish
lithuania and cyprus overtake spain and
gdp per capita
and that is not all according to world
bank data lithuania is in the same
position as estonia also ahead of spain
in gdp per capita adjusted for the price
difference and everything points to
latvia being able to reach the same
point in no time however the journey has
not exactly been a leisurely stroll in
the woods the baltic countries had to
face one of the biggest bubbles and
crises in the old continent within
living memory however they faced it in a
completely different way than we are
used to we've prepared this video along
with our friends from value school it is
the story of the miracle collapse and
recovery of the so-called baltic tigers
listen up
[Music]
when the baltic states regained their
independence in 1991 after more than 50
years under soviet rule they practically
had to start from scratch among other
things this meant having to design and
implement their own economic policies
including of course fiscal and monetary
policy so where do you start what
exactly should you prioritize which
model should you choose after five
decades of centrally planned policies it
was time for change and to achieve
change they needed to secure one key
ingredient stability
and you see the three baltic republics
knew exactly what they were three small
countries unknown in the international
sphere and very poor at that time if one
thing was clear it was that estonia
latvia and lithuania needed the
collaboration of international investors
and companies to promote their growth
and boost their development but this is
easier said than done in order to get
foreign capital into the baltic these
three countries had to inspire
confidence and for that they had to have
stability political stability social
stability and also economic stability
that is to have things like healthy
public accounts an efficient financial
system and low inflation but of course
the question that estonians latvians and
lithuanians ask themselves and that we
can also ask ourselves is how can this
be achieved how can we achieve economic
stability well this is exactly where the
debate on the types of changes arises
that is the debate between choosing a
fixed exchange rate model where your
currency can be converted to another
currency at a fixed rate or a flexible
exchange rate model where exchange rates
depend entirely on the market and this
is no small matter the advantage of
flexible exchange rates is that they
allow an economy to better adjust to an
economic shock or an international
crisis fixed exchange rates on the other
hand by allowing exchange rate risk to
disappear tend to achieve higher levels
of confidence among international
investors and therefore greater access
to international financing and also
lower rates the downside is that they
severely limit a country's adjustment
capacity well the fact is that the three
baltic republics opted for fixed
exchange rates thus estonia's new
currency the croon was pegged at a fixed
rate to the deutsche mark the lithuanian
litas was pegged to the us dollar and
the latvian lat was pegged to the imf's
drawing rights a real grab bag of the
world's major currencies in other words
the three baltic republics basically
gave up having their own independent
monetary policy from that moment on
keeping the exchange rate fixed became
more than a priority it also became a
national duty
[Music]
and believe me when i tell you they did
it against all odds but we'll talk about
that later the point for now is that
their strategy sort of worked during the
late 1990s and the beginning of the
current century foreign capital
particularly from nordic countries and
above all from sweden began to pour into
the baltic republics as if there was no
tomorrow this flood of capital fueled an
enormous economic takeoff with growth
rates reaching over 10 per annum
suddenly estonia latvia and lithuania
became the great protagonists of change
the baltic miracle was underway
[Music]
the downside is that this massive influx
of international capital meant that
these three countries maintained large
current account deficits for years the
problem is that maintaining large
current account deficits over the long
term is something that tends to fuel
serious economic problems for example in
this case easy access to cheap
international credits multiplied
corporate debt and overheated the
housing market and that's not all as is
always the case the flood of credit also
boosted asset prices and financed a huge
trade imbalance for years credit was
almost unlimited remember that the
nordic banks especially the banks in
sweden were doing great business they
took very cheap capital from their home
countries and poured it into the baltic
states in exchange for slightly higher
rates and since the demand for credit
was enormous the business just kept
growing and growing in fact over time
these same banks ended up controlling
more than two-thirds of the entire
financial system of the baltic states
estonia latvia and lithuania became the
golden goose for swedish banking and all
within just a few years the point is
that with so much credit asset bubbles
and problems associated with excessive
debts began to pop up everywhere this
open bar of nordic credit fed a huge
economic take-off in the baltic
republics but also huge financial
imbalances the hangover was gonna be
rough listen up
[Music]
in free fall
perhaps the ingredients that fed the
crisis in the baltic states were not so
different from those we have already
seen on other occasions unlimited
credits real estate bubbles over
indebtedness of companies and so on and
so forth however what was completely
different was the response of these
three countries to the crisis and of the
three the case of latvia is perhaps the
most representative we are talking about
one of the country's most affected by
the 2008 crisis in the world a country
whose gdp fell by more than 25 between
2008 and 2010. yes really 25 and their
unemployment rate was not far behind
registered unemployment rose above 20
percent
[Music]
but let's start at the beginning by 2007
the latvian banking market was dominated
by four large banks three swedish banks
swedbank seb and nordy and one local
bank parex bank well as we have already
mentioned the business basically
consisted of the following these
entities particularly the three big
swedish banks financed themselves very
cheaply in their markets of origin and
then derived large amounts of loans in
the three baltic republics in this way
credit was not tied to deposits or any
other local resource the supply was in
practice unlimited
[Music]
banks could lend as much as they wanted
and even more it was kind of a financial
free-for-all what's more as this massive
flood of credit spread through the
economy demand for all kinds of goods
and services increased and with that
inflation which in turn and this is
important drove real interest rates
deeper and deeper into negative
territory think about it the rates at
which loans were traded depended
primarily on the international market so
as inflation climbed as demand grew in
the baltic republics real rates sank
lower and lower in turn this made taking
out more and more loans the most
rational decision and you know what
that's exactly what happened
[Music]
take a look at this other graph the
levels of investment in latvia were very
high well above the levels of local
savings and foreign direct investment we
are talking about a difference that came
to represent 18 of gdp and that of
course had to be covered by all the
torrential loans that came from abroad
[Music]
loans that also financed a growing trade
deficit the wheels did not stop turning
until stop along came 2007 and the
international financial crisis at that
time the imbalances in latvia estonia
and lithuania were so large that the
balloon was well and truly ready to
burst
[Music]
and that is exactly what happened from
2007 onwards the flow of credit slowed
down more and more until by the end of
2008 the international markets were
practically dry suddenly real estate
prices began to fall there were no more
resources to finance the higher levels
of investment and many hyper-leveraged
companies began to go bankrupt which in
turn triggered unemployment and with
that even more defaults for example
parex bank the second largest bank in
the country and the largest local bank
had to be rescued by the government
[Music]
the latvian economy went into freefall
and with it the public deficit began to
climb almost exponentially but there was
a problem international financial
markets were dry and in this case
governments could not adjust monetary
policy unless they agreed to end the
fixed exchange rate model it was time to
make adjustments and boy did they make
them
[Music]
the imf recommended that they devalue
their currencies and many economists
urged them to use monetary policy to
finance stimulus plans to deal with the
crisis however no the answer from the
baltics and in particular from latvia
which was the country that had the most
financial problems due to having to
rescue a large local bank was a
resounding no
[Music]
and here we come to the key point this
was the surprising response that latvia
along with the other baltic states gave
to the 2008 financial crisis an
aggressive unique and surprisingly bold
response to give you an idea in just
over a year the government implemented a
fiscal adjustment plan of almost 11
points of gdp this meant cutting all
public spending by more than 25
more than a quarter in just a few months
latvia did what had always been thought
to be impossible
by the end of 2009 the government had
already announced the dismissal of 29
of all public employees while reducing
the salaries of the remaining civil
servants by an average of 26 that's not
all it was also decided to take
advantage of the moment to reorganize
the entire state structure from top to
bottom for example it was announced that
35 of the country's 59 hospitals would
be closed because they were considered
obsolete and unnecessary it was also
announced that more than 100 public
schools would be closed and that some 2
400 professionals would be laid off half
of all public agencies were closed and
salaries in state-controlled enterprises
were capped we are talking about a
titanic effort that was carried out with
a very clear idea not to touch the
economic foundations of the country and
its main source of long-term prosperity
the fixed exchange rates the flat tax
system and healthy public accounts with
such an eye and will on the table the
government negotiated a support package
with the imf the european commission and
the scandinavian countries which totaled
some 7.5 billion a package of which
latvia barely used a little more than
half in the end
then in 2010 the economy began to come
back to life the crisis was coming to an
end and although the effort had been
hard and unemployment had climbed above
20 percent the country emerged from the
crisis without touching its economic
foundations and with reasonably healthy
public accounts by the end of 2010
public debt represented only 42 percent
of gdp this was the case in latvia but
the stories of estonia and lithuania
were very similar
[Music]
unlike the other republics that emerged
with the dismantling of the soviet union
the three baltic musketeers opted for a
radical change of economic model in a
few years they did away with subsidies
privatized the bulk of public companies
established a competitive tax model
under a proportional system in which all
taxpayers faced the same tax rate and
opted for the containment of public
spending even through the worst of times
these three countries held the rudder
steady the result is clear to see
[Music]
so there you have the story of one of
the biggest crises in europe in recent
decades a crisis a real estate and
credit bubble that nevertheless had a
very different ending to the one that we
are used to today estonia lithuania and
latvia are three prosperous countries
with very high levels of
entrepreneurship and growing levels of
competitiveness but having come to this
point it's time to stop what do you
think of the baltic republic's response
to the 2008 crisis leave us your answer
below in the comments and if this video
made in collaboration with value school
has been interesting for you then don't
forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik best regards i'll see you
next time
[Music]